south of the sahara's niger's tilaberry
region by the malian border is a remote
refugee camp where people live in fear
they're mostly women and children from
neighboring mali fleeing what they say
is an unstoppable spiral of violence in
their homeland across the border they
thought they would be safe
but here too armed groups linked
al-qaeda and isil come to kill them
what do you say i remember the day the
bandits came and killed one of us and
left with another afterwards they
ordered us to leave the village everyone
children old people and us women we all
came here on foot
fourteen thousand u.n peacekeepers have
been deployed in mali for almost a
decade but this 1 billion a year u.n
operation has failed to bring peace
attacks are spreading beyond mali to
neighboring countries on a five-day tour
of west africa the u.n secretary general
antonio gutierrez makes an impromptu
visit to the camp
you can count on me to demand from the
international community strong support
for the army of niger so that it has the
capacity to protect you better most here
don't know who he is they watch
quizzically as he plants a mango tree in
the sand
there hasn't been any rainfall for
almost a year with armed groups trying
to control water points climate change
too is fueling the conflict
the situation in the sahel is complex
characterized by insecurity but also
climate change which has an impact on
displaced and host populations it is for
these reasons that we ask you mr
secretary general to continue to make
our situation one of your priorities
earlier he traveled to senegal meeting
with the african union chairman
prices of food and fuel are on the rise
in africa the u.n estimates a quarter of
a billion people could plunge into
extreme poverty by the end of the year
as the result of the ukraine-russia
conflict
while he did not travel to mali the
situation in that country is high on the
agenda ali's military junta is telling
efforts to return power to civilian rule
human rights group accused malian
soldiers and recently deployed russian
fighters linked to the wagner group of
torture and perpetrating massacres on
civilians
it has become increasingly difficult for
the un
to fulfill its mandate of protecting the
malian people
many of whom are now fleeing their
country
nicholas hawk al jazeera